at a transport secretary Mark Harper has
been speaking in the last few minutes
following news that rmt union members at
Network rail have voted to accept a
payoffer let's take a listen so a deal
at last on the network rail side of
things could this not have been done
much earlier if you'd enabled it
well we did enable it from the moment I
became transport secretary I tried to
change the tone of this debate uh
facilitated a fair and reasonable
payoffer and also met with all of the
rail union leaders to try and get us to
this position I'm very pleased now on
behalf of the traveling public that at
least on the network rail side of the
rail business that we've now solved the
industrial disputes across all of the
trade unions I'm very pleased with a
very resounding decision today by
Network rail members 90 turnout 76 voted
in favor of what was of a fair and
reasonable offer if the whole dispute's
going to be solved though surely you're
going to have to put more money on the
table to get the train company side
solved as well well we were very clear
that this deal that's been done on
network rail consisted of two parts it
consisted of Reform to the way that
Network rail operates that's been
accepted and that is gonna go ahead and
a fair and reasonable hasn't been
accepted well it has been accepted
because this Deal's been except and
network rally is proceeding with its
modernizing maintenance program so that
reform is going to take place and I'm
very pleased at the same time that
reform is going to take place Network
rail staff are going to get a fair and
reasonable payoffer and that's the the
right thing to do this deal was within
the Mandate that was set out for Network
Rail and I hope that the trade unions
now put the rmt now put the fair and
reasonable payoff of very similar pay
offer that they now put that to their
members that are working for the train
operating companies they haven't had the
chance to consider this pay offer and I
hope their Union gives them the chance
to consider it and did decide whether
like their Network rail workers whether
they want to settle this dispute as well
but why should they do that when they
haven't had a new offer well they
haven't had a chance to consider the
offer at all Network rail staff had two
votes on pay offers the train operating
company staff and they have on the table
a fair and reasonable offer that's
comparable to the one that's just been
accepted by Network rail staff they
haven't had the chance to consider it at
all so my plea to the rmt is put this
offer very fair and reasonable offer
comparable to the one that your members
of overwhelmingly in your own words
accepted on network rail put it to your
members that work for train operating
companies let them decide whether they
want to get back to work serve the
traveling public and deliver a better
train service for the people that they
serve who do you think linked first in
this dispute well look I don't think
it's about who's blinked first it's
about a fair and reasonable offer was on
the table the rmt finally put it in
front of their members and their members
have overwhelmingly accepted it because
I think fundamentally people that work
on our Railways want a fair pay offer
but they also want to serve the
traveling public and they want to
improve the industry in which they work
and they've overwhelmingly voted in
favor of that payoff today I'm glad we
can get the payoff for done we can get
the reforms delivered to the industry
that we can hopefully get the industry
back on track track after what's been a
very difficult three years with the
impact of the pandemic do you think the
train company side much might be much
harder to resolve because actually
there's a lot more conditions attached a
lot of which the members are very
unhappy with and the r d was talking
about an unconditional payoffer when it
rejected that last offer well look I
think our message has been very clear
there's got to be reform it's reform
that's helping to fund these pay offers
and I think you've got to have both
parts together I've I said in my George
Bradshaw address last month that the
rail industry finances at the moment are
unsustainable and you've got to deliver
reform in order to have these fair and
reasonable payoff as that's what the
staff or network rail have accepted and
I hope that those on the train operating
company can do so as well she's done
something else are you comfortable
supporting a deal on Northern Ireland
that the dup says it Rejects well look
obviously I've been very focused today
on dealing with the outcome of this
industrial dispute and the good news
that we've had so I haven't had a great
deal of time to look at what the dup
have said but I do know that the Windsor
Frameworks a very powerful deal it was a
deal that no one thought that the Prime
Minister could reach it settles a lot of
the Practical issues that there have
been for the people of Northern Ireland
and I think it enables trade to continue
within the UK internal Market I know the
House of Commons is planned to have a
vote on it this week I think it's a good
deal and I hope a majority of members of
the House of commas will support it very
quick final one
you've extended the Avanti West Coast
contract again are you not rewarding
failure not at all of anti have
demonstrated over the period running to
in this contract this six-month period
that they've made considerable
improvements which is why I've had
sufficient confidence to extend their
contract by six months but they still
have quite some way to go which is why
I've only extended it for six months and
I will be looking for continued
Improvement in performance in the months
to come